ouais
la birmanie coupées du monde après les
émeutes les affrontements il ya
plusieurs centaines de morts le régime
birman se défend pied à pied nouvelles
inquiétudes sur les marchés financiers
le dollar est à 6 francs 48 c'est la
conséquence de la hausse des taux
d'escompté américain
cyclisme la grande valse dans les
équipes françaises l'équipe systèmes
huppert ses champions cyrille guimard
s'explique
bonsoir est tout d'abord un regard pour
commencer ce journal un instantané sur
l'été chinois hier soir laurent cabrol
vous montrer les conséquences
dramatiques du passage d'un typhon dans
le zhejiang
il y avait eu une centaine de morts et
bien cette fois d'une autre manière nous
allons voir comment dans ces pays
immense les phénomènes climatiques
prennent d'étonnantes proportion cette
fois c'est la canicule
jean corneille et françoise joly
reportage il est 15h température
extérieure 46 degrés à l'ombre
orhan le four du centre de la chine dans
cette ville l'une des premières choses
que l'on vous dit ici il y à 104
ventilateur pour 100 familles un
ventilateur c'est un mois de salaire et
travailler devient un véritable exploit
même si les horaires ont été réduits de
8 heures à 6 heures par jour la libye
inculpation est obligé de travailler les
ponts thermiques du peuple au service du
peuple et privilégier commerçants 7
hommes possèdent un réfrigérateur coût
de l'achat milian soit près d'un an d'un
salaire moyen
et c'est grâce au yang tsé kiang le
fleuve qui traverse houran que la
population va trouver un peu de répit
lorsque la nuit tombe
une brise se lève on va pouvoir enfin
dormir
enfin presque
en france les négociations sur la
nouvelle calédonie elle progresse le
rpcr et le fln ks vont envoyer deux
délégations à paris pour poursuivre ses
négociations avec le gouvernement dans
les prochains jours tout cela sur fond
d'une rencontre secrète qui aurait eu
lieu ces jours derniers dans le
territoire entre jean marie tjibaou et
jacques lafleur rachid arhab se sont-ils
revu depuis la poignée de main
historique du 26 juin à matignon jean
marie tjibaou et jacques lafleur sont
retournés en nouvelle calédonie pour
tenter de convaincre leurs bases
respectives sans problème pour le chef
du rpcr avec difficulté pour le leader
indépendantiste jean-marie tjibaou
dément avoir rencontré hier jacques
lafleur
il faut dire que le président du fn k s
a bien du mal avec les durs de son
mouvement
les indépendantistes ans rencontrée
plusieurs fois le haut-commissaire de
nouméa
ils lui ont transmis leurs doléances
réponse de matignon pas de nouvelles
discussions si le hc sierre n'est pas
d'accord et ce parti ne semble pas
d'accord malgré tout à paris on estime
que les fils du dialogue ne sont pas
rompus
le ministre des dom tom à lens même une
nouvelle rencontre la semaine prochaine
à paris entre le rpcr et le fine gael le
gouvernement avait souhaité après des
accords matignon que le dialogue ait
lieu à nouméa
c'est ce qui s'est passé c'est tout
dernières semaines c'est tout derniers
jours j'ai un peu le sentiment qu'à
présent il y as place pour le dialogue à
paris et je forme l'espoir de recevoir
la semaine prochaine une délégation du
fln caisse et du rpcr afin de leur
présenter le projet de loi référendaire
qui portent l'organisation de la
nouvelle calédonie pour les 10 ans qui
viennent
mais chacun comprendra que la densité de
ce texte plus de 120 articles la
complexité des problèmes requiert du
temps mais à ce jour le calendrier tel
qu'il était pensé au moment de la
signature des accords matignon est tout
simplement respecter au ministère des
dom tom comme à matignon on affirme donc
qu'il faut prendre son temps
michel rocard qui rentrent de vacances
ce soir décidera dans les prochains
jours de l'opportunité d'un déplacement
sur place pour le premier ministre le
dossier calédonien sera le premier test
de la rentrée politique
le président mitterrand se rendra aux
états unis en septembre prochain le 25
précisément il rencontrera le président
reagan la veille le président français
s'exprimera à la tribune de l'onu
des élections législatives partielles
dans l'oise les 11 et 18 septembre
prochains le conseil constitutionnel
avait annulé l'élection des deux
candidats eu r c'est dans ce département
la sncf toujours la polémique sur la
sécurité le juge d'instruction chargé de
l'enquêté vient de nommer deux experts
et pour la première fois la commission
denquête s'est réuni sur les lieux mêmes
de l'accident qui je vous le rappelle a
fait un mort et 57 blessés samedi
dernier gare de l'est
ce soir la cfdt accusent la direction
d'avoir perturbé l'enquète pascal
deschamps premier sujet d'étonnement
pour la cfdt
très vite la motrice du train accidenté
a été séparé du reste des wagons ce qui
rend plus difficile
l'examen du système de transmission dans
son ensemble c'est un type de matériel
ou des difficultés de transmission avait
été observé pas forcément sur cette
machine aller sur ce type de matériel
ces difficultés de transmission était
essentiellement due à des phénomènes de
condensation dans les transmissions
partant de fortes chaleurs est ce que
c'est ça qui est en cause dans cet
accident ça sera l'entrée dû rétablir le
l'ensemble ayant été débranché deuxième
problème les fiches d'intervention comme
celle-ci remplit par les mécaniciens et
qui mentionnait ces fameuses incidents
de transmission ont disparu hier
pourrait apparaître ce matin et les
syndicats de conclure la sncf a voulu
perturber les enquêtes
pas du tout répond on à la direction la
motrice a été séparée sur ordre du
procureur de la république
quant aux fiches d'intervention elles
ont sans doute été examiné par la
direction du matériel puis remise aux
enquêteurs restent la rumeur selon
laquelle la motrice accidenté aurait
déjà eu des problèmes avant l'accident
ces problèmes ayant été signalée jeudi
par mesure d'apporter une réponse
précise par contre si un incident avait
empêché une conduite normale le l'un des
conducteurs aurait demandé ce qu'on
appelle la réserve
la locomotive n'aurait pu circuler s'il
y avait une telle inscription qu'un
accord mais je ne voudrais surtout pas
que ce soit une fois de plus interprétés
comme penchant vers l'erreur humaine
mais s'il y avait une telle inscription
le conducteur averti
elle n'aurait pu être encore plus
vigilant sur ce point une réponse qui
n'empêchera pas la polémique entre
direction et syndicats de continuer
défaillance technique contre erreur
humaine
pendant ce temps l'enquêté continue les
marchés financiers ont de nouveau la
fièvre le dollar cotait aujourd'hui 6
francs 48 forte hausse donc à paris
conséquence immédiate une forte baisse
des bourses comme deal afp à paris le
chiffre était de moins 1,0 8% pour
l'indicateur de tendance des valeurs en
tout cas le spectre du krach boursier
d'octobre dernier donc re donne des
frissons à tous les hommes de finances
la principale raison de cette fièvre
c'est la hausse des taux d'escompté aux
états unis jacquat bouchard alan
greenspan président de la réserve
fédérale a pris tout le monde à
contre-pied hier en décidant d'augmenter
d'un demi point à 6 et demi pour cent le
taux d'escompté de la banque centrale
américaine
raison invoquée juguler tout dérapage
inflationniste
alors que l'économie va bien et que
jamais autant d'américains noté t au
travail
conséquence immédiate le cac a grimpé et
wall street la bourse de new york a fait
connaître sa mauvaise humeur en
clôturant par une baisse de plus de 28
points la journée de mardi le
porte-parole de la maison-blanche
marlene fils voiteur a exprimé la
déception du président reagan
alors que monsieur george bush en pleine
campagne électorale a jugé nécessaire le
relèvement du taux d'escompté par le
candidat démocrate michael dukakis a
déclaré voilà ce qui arrive quand on est
criblé de dettes et que l'on accumule
chaque année 150 milliards de dollars de
déficit
wall street était toujours aussi
réserver ce matin avec une nette
tendance à la baisse la bourse de new
york est mal remise du krach d'octobre
dernier et certains financiers
souligne que l'effondrement des cours
avait alors fait suite à la précédente
augmentation du taux d'escompté de la
réserve fédérale cela fait aux états
unis donc philippe sassier est ce que
cette nouvelle fièvre des marchés
financiers s'oppose à la politique
économique du gouvernement c'est michel
rocard donc en fait elle s'oppose bien
sûr d'abord à la politique des taux
d'intérêt le gouvernement français
voulait la faire baisser absolument
garder claude ce que l'on peut dire
c'est que pour l'instant le gouvernement
en france écarte toute hausse des taux
d'intérêt en france il faut souhaiter
que c'est de guerre des toe déclenchée
entre les états unis l'angleterre
l'allemagne ne dégénère pas sinon la
situation française sera difficile ce
que l'on peut dire en tout cas c'est que
cette politique de baisse des taux en
france amorcée par monsieur bérégovoy et
probablement stoppée et stoppé pour un
certain moment pour combien de temps
cela toute la question
probablement au moins jusqu'à la fin de
cette année parce que on l'a bien senti
à travers le reportage de jacques à
bouchard la période des présidentielles
américaines va entraîner un certain
nombre de troubles sur les marchés
financiers parce qu'on va tenter de
savoir ce que vont vouloir les deux
candidats en revanche si au début de
l'an prochain en début de 1989
on commence à anticiper un
ralentissement des coûts de américaine
qui tourne très très vite à qui il
manquait presque en surchauffe et bien
on pourrait reconnaître tout se passe
bien
une période de tension un peu moins
grande sur les taux d'intérêt à ce
moment là on pourrait espérer que la
france renoue avec cette baisse des taux
d'intérêt
philippe à ce que le franc pourrait être
menacée côté pour l'instant il ne l'est
pas il n'y a pas de raison pour qu'il le
soit et c'est une bonne chose parce que
s'il était bien ce ne serait pas une
pause de la baisse des taux d'intérêt
que l'on devrait faire face mais à une
hausse de ses taux d'intérêt pour éviter
une attaque sur le front et une hausse
des taux d'intérêt il faut que les
performances de la france en matière de
prix ne soit pas remise en cause et au
gouvernement on insiste sur deux grands
problèmes économiques d'abord les prix
on va surveiller de très très près les
prix des services là pas de dérapage
deuxièmement les salaires on ne donnera
probablement un petit coup de pouce
mais là aussi ce coup de pouce sera
parfaitement maîtriser cela signifie
donc que cette politique menée aux états
unis conduit la france il ne veut pas
monter ses taux à coller de très très
près la rigueur
dernier point le krach de wall street
s'était il y a dix mois précisément
est-ce que c'était pas les mêmes
symptômes
exactement il
à dix mois il y avait une guéguerre
ghetto qui a conduit à ce grand boum de
la bourse américaine et aujourd'hui on
se demande effectivement si on ne va pas
reconnaître à quel tracts ce que l'on
peut dire c'est d'abord qu'il ya
beaucoup moins de spéculation une part
que les bourses sont assis dis donc le
danger paraît beaucoup moins grand qu'il
y a dix mois ce qui inquiète
actuellement les gens du gouvernement
c'est cette hausse du dollar car on se
demande au gouvernement français qui a
envie qui a envie d'empêcher ceux de
l'art de s'envoler trop fort merci
philippe et puisque nous parlons
chiffres cette information encore la
redevance télé va augmenter de 6 9%
ainsi donc pour la couleur vous devrez
payer 5 141 francs et 356 francs pour
nous voir en noir et blanc la birmanie
dans la tourmente
exemple de la violence des émeutes selon
radio rangoon capté à bangkok en
thaïlande
six policiers ont été tués tout à
l'heure en birmanie dont 3 décapité on
sait que les émeutes contre l'actuel
chef de l'état ne cesse pas on sait
qu'il y a déjà eu plusieurs centaines de
morts pour le reste c'est l'inconnu car
ce petit pays coincé entre l'inde la
chine et la thaïlande est en ce moment
coupée du monde
jacques merlino aujourd'hui encore
rangoon capitale la birmanie et
plusieurs villes de province ont été le
théâtre de très violents affrontements
entre manifestants et forces de l'ordre
les manifestations qui durent depuis
plusieurs jours et qui donne lieu à de
véritables scènes de carnage l'armée et
la police dépassée par les événements
ont à plusieurs reprises tiré dans la
foule et le bilan officieux serait de
plus de 200 morts à l'origine de ces
manifestations une crise économique sans
précédent
ce pays situé entre l'inde et la
thaïlande était autrefois le premier
exportateur mondial de riz l'an dernier
ils demandaient son inscription sur la
liste des pays les plus pauvres des
nations unies crise économique mais
aussi crise politique nouveau dirigeant
de la birmanie le général c'est new line
que l'on voit ici le jour de sa
désignation par le parti unique est
surnommé le boucher de rangoon par les
étudiants c'est lui qui en mars et juin
dernier
à diriger la répression contre les
manifestations estudiantines répression
qui s'était traduite par la mort d'une
centaine de jeunes manifestants depuis
jeudi dernier la loi martiale est en
vigueur les magasins ont tiré le rideau
de fer les transports et le téléphone
sont paralysées et toutes les écoles ont
été fermées sur ordre du gouvernement
selon les dernières informations que
nous venons d'obtenir plusieurs postes
de police seraient tombées cet après
midi aux mains des opposants
la birmanie ce soir est quasiment en
état insurrectionnel bagdad aujourd'hui
le premier détachement d'observateurs de
l'onu est arrivé c'est cinq hommes vont
mettre en place les mesures pratiques du
cessez le feu un autre contingent de
cinq officiers vient aussi d'arriver à
téhéran pour une tâche similaire
ici ce sont des canadiens qui embarque
il s'apprête à se rendre sur les lieux
du conflit ils feront partie de la force
de l'onu chargé de faire respecter le
cessez le feu
la date officielle du cessez-le-feu
c'est samedi le 20 août et le 25 août
les négociations commenceront à genève
mais déjà on peut déterminer est les
conséquences pratiques de l'arrêt des
combats
gilles rabin les marins et les pilotes
du porte hélicoptères américains
guadalcanal vont bientôt pouvoir rentrer
au pays
c'est l'une des conséquences les plus
prévisibles du cessez-le-feu
le désengagement prochain des navires de
guerre américains anglais et français
qui depuis un an escorte ou accompagnent
les pétroliers dans le golfe persique
d'ailleurs dès l'annoncé du cessez le
feu les primes d'assurance ont baissé
pour ses pétroliers du golfe
mais ce retrait est assujettie aux
règlements du processus de remise en
état du chott el arab cet estuaire dont
l'iran et l'irak se disputent la
souveraineté équipe pendant huit ans a
été le théâtre des combats les plus
acharnés pour les deux pays
l'enjeu que représente le chott el arab
est vital il s'agit tout simplement de
ré ouvrir au plus vite la route naturel
du pétrole relancer la production de
pétrole est une urgence pour l'irak
comme pour l'iran les deux belligérants
ont besoin d'argent un point tel qu'ils
inquiètent les monarchies pétrolières de
l'opep que tout surproduction affole
l'iran et l'irak doit financer en effet
la reconstruction des zones détruites
les centres urbains touche
les missiles les raffineries les ports
les usines bombardé la zone des combats
qui s'allonge presque 650 kg mais la
facture totale est estimée à au moins
1000 milliards de francs l'iran et
l'irak vont aussi devoir apprendre à
gérer politiquement leurs millions
d'anciens combattants la paix revenue
c'est l'avenir de la révolution
islamique qui va se jouer en iran les
dissensions féroce longtemps étouffée
par la guerre vont s'exprimer au grand
jour en irak
c'est l'avenir du régime de saddam
hussein qui est en jeu hussein qui se
méfie déjà de ses généraux couvert de
gloire par huit en guerre et qui peuvent
devenir des concurrents
l'heure de vérité pour les deux régimes
la paix en iran et en irak se fera sans
aucun doute sur le dos des résistants
kurdes en guerre permanente contre
saddam hussein est soutenu par l'iran
moi jean du peuple opposés aux
ayatollahs et entretenus par l'irak
le cessez-le-feu entre l'irak et l'iran
devrait enfin permettre une libération
plus rapide
les derniers otages occidentaux retenu
au liban cette information de dernière
minute tout à l'heure un bateau
touristique égyptien fait naufrage sur
le nil à cause d'une très violente
tempête il y avait une centaine de
passagers à bord il y aurait 26 noyer
dont six étrangers
les victimes étrangères seraient des
touristes italiens tout de suite le
reste de l'actualité internationale
en bref en images jérôme baugnies
avec ces trois puissances flamme
l'espoir renaît à cap canaveral à
plusieurs fois reporté sept essais des
moteurs de la navette discovery a
finalement bien marcher affirme le
porte-parole de la nasa
un cinquième test sera effectué dans
huit jours avant le lancement lui même
fin septembre début octobre qui
permettra le retour des astronautes
américains dans l'espace pour la
première fois depuis le tragique
accident de janvier 86
dix sept ans après fidel castro remet
les pieds sur le continent sud-américain
à quito on les cérémonies d'investiture
du nouveau président équatorien
le social-démocrate rodrigo borgia la
dernière fois c'était dans le chili dyan
des en 1971 au président sortant
conservateur venus l'accueillir
le lider maximo a déclaré que cette
invitation était une preuve
d'indépendance vis-à-vis de ceux qui
voient d'un mauvais oeil un
rapprochement au cuba équateur
images diffusées par la télévision
soviétique elle mène de la deuxième
ville d'afghanistan kandahar après neuf
ans d'une difficile occupation par
l'armée rouge
une ville évacué depuis jeudi par le
contingent soviétique qui aurait fait
revu au moins dix-huit hommes pendant le
retrait aujourd'hui c'est l'armée
afghane seul avec quelques centaines de
conseillers soviétiques qui doit
résister à l'encerclement de 11000
moudjahidine tout le cheptel d'un
éleveur allemand felix ligne placé sous
séquestre au moins 4200 de ses quatorze
mille vols ont été fixées aux hormones
pour le ministre de l'environnement du
land de rhénanie westphalie
il s'agit du plus grand scandale jamais
découvert en allemagne fédérale
l'indignation également les organisation
allemande de défense des consommateurs
pour lesquels cette affaire montre que
l'injection d'hormones aux bêtes
d'élevage est une pratique courante
ceci encore venise summer venise est
presque morte cela fait des siècles que
la sérénissime s'enfonce dans les vases
de sa lagune et le charme de ses palais
vient aussi de leur lente désagrégation
il n'empêche la pollution les algues et
la chaleur mène une attaque des plus
sévères cet été venise est envahi venise
sans la pourriture dominique verdeilhan
habit vert pour une cité qui se voudrait
immortel la guinée grand canal sont
envahis par des tonnes d'algues dont
certaines atteignent la taille d'un drap
une véritable serre artificielle qui
provoque la mort par asphyxie de
centaines de poissons et crustacés
conséquence une prolifération de petits
insectes gras qui envahissent par
milliards les canaux et habitation de
venise les couches de ces insectes morts
atteignent jusqu'à 30 centimètres c'est
moissonneuses marine au nombre de quatre
sont pour l'instant la seule arme pour
endiguer cette marée verte
chaque machine rama 500 tonnes d'algues
par jour une intervention jugée
insuffisante par les écologistes
devant l'ampleur de la pollution
responsable de cette prolifération
l'accumulation depuis une dizaine
d'années de déchets industriels et
urbains et l'absence totale des goûts à
venise
sans oublier ces trois jeunes hommes qui
font vivre la cité au rythme des marées
de la mer adriatique à venise depuis
longtemps il ne fait pas bon vivre
au rez de chaussée ces jours derniers la
forte chaleur à accélérer le processus
de décomposition des algues engendrant
une odeur nauséabonde d'oeuf pourri pour
sauver venise des eaux
on parle des cluses de contrôle strict
des et charges industrielles et d'égout
mais ce ne sont peut-être que des
soupirs une expérience étonnante
d'isolement total vient de démarrer dans
l'aveyron sous terre pendant trois mois
c'est l'exploit que va tenter une jeune
femme la voix si une jeune femme de 32
ans véronique le guen c'est le
spéléologue michel siffre le responsable
de cette expérience véronique va vivre à
82 mètres de profondeur au milieu d'une
tonne et demie de vivres et d'eau et
aussi au milieu d'un millier de livres
elle va perdre très vite la notion du
temps à la surface les scientifiques
analyseront ces rythmes biologiques et
ses cycles de sommeil
cette expérience aura des applications
pratiques de grand intérêt par exemple
une meilleure
description des médicaments en fonction
des heures de la journée
cyclisme la grande déroute de certaines
équipes françaises après le tour de
france c'est le cas de l'équipe système
u qui perd tous ses champions ou presque
en fait les meilleurs français ils ne
sont d'ailleurs pas très nombreux il
faut bien le dire les meilleurs français
s'en vont généralement pour rejoindre
des équipes étrangères
enquête alain vernon cyrille guimard
n'arrête pas ils n'arrêtent pas
d'expliquer que charly mottet est parti
en bons termes mais qu'au bout d'un an
mottez a fini par craquer il n'a pas
voulu quitter l'équipe et puis cette
année va je dirais que les propositions
qu'il a eue était tel que moi je ne
pourrais pas me lire les chiffres 270
mille francs par mois chez système u
mottez passe à 250 milles cheikh mbow
l'entreprise de travail temporaire de
grenoble sa région une fortune pour vous
juste le temps pour lui de préparer
l'avenir en quelques années de carrière
même aubaine pour eric boyer qui vaut
aujourd'hui 150 mille francs par mois
avec une cinquième place sur le tour de
france qui préoccupe dit marc la méthode
des concurrents pour piller les bonnes
équipes dont trois au quatre ans sont
des coureurs que l'on forme et qu'on a
mal qu'on amène au plus haut niveau le
jour ils sont au plus haut niveau de
toute façon à partir de ce moment là
vous avez des groupes qui se sont
constituées lors seul objectif d' assez
d'essayer d'avoir les coureurs les plus
renommés du moment pour avoir des
retombées médiatiques mais diable
accumulé l'argent comme les points
mottez et boyer ont choisi de monnayer
leur talent de champion cyril guimard
avait trois leaders sur le tour il n'en
reste qu'un finhan alors coureurs fini
si on peut dire aujourd'hui que laurence
remote encore fini ça veut dire qu'il
n'ya plus un seul coureur qu'on soit
dans le peloton puisque le seul qui
gagne les grandes courses
selon philippe laurent fignon qui ne
suffit plus pour séduire les sponsors
système u repartira sur le bout des
doigts avec la banda guimard le
dénicheur de talents mais si la seule
équipe 100% française retrouve un budget
de 16 millions de francs ailleurs
systémique ne s'accrochera pas et
guimard partira à la recherche de futurs
champions
un résultat de sport encore il s'agit de
rugby c'est la coupe du monde
universitaire l alliance mans en france
l'équipe de france justement vient de
battre celle d'argentine 19 à 12
et puis encore des images insolites
extravagantes parfois claude chris paul
et commentent à commencer par elton john
le chanteur veut changer de vie alors il
brade son passé il le vend aux enchères
chez sotheby's
quel est le second prénom d'elton john
allez je vous le donne gratuitement
hercules
ce qui en revanche sera achetée c'est
tout ce qu'il ya un sa maison deux mille
objets estimés entre 3 et 4 millions et
qu'ils cèdent pour dit il changer
d'atmosphère
atmosphère atmosphère sur ces images il
a vraiment une tête atmosphère elton et
dans sept écuries d'augias
normal pour un hercule vous y trouverez
des bottes pour pied bot quelques paires
de lunettes les plus discrets pour
musiciens me up des objets d'art déco et
même un masque vénitien sans doute pour
cacher cette avalanche de mauvais goût
plus rafraîchissant ce canin qui luttent
contre la canicule
rocchi fait du surf depuis qu'il est
chiot sur cet objet que les spécialistes
auront identifié comme un goût du board
à lui les grandes lames californienne du
regret sa combinaison rock qui n'aiment
pas le fluo et l'intransigeance de 100 m
qui ne veut pas lui donner un look man
part dans un baladeur le bonheur même
des chiens n'est pas en mer alors
peut-être dans les airs avec cette
solution pour éviter radicalement les
bouchons 30 mètres entre les deux
immeubles à 28 mètres du sol des heures
de gagner présence indispensable en cinq
courses d'un dentiste 7 incisive façon
de détourner les encombrements peut
avoir quelquefois des conséquences
fâcheuses
insolite encore ce film qui sort en
france sur les écrans ce mercredi il
s'appelle le soviet alors vous prenez
rambo mais vous inversez les rôles
les bons sont soviétique et les méchants
américains bien sûr le héros le soviet
ont réussi par son action à préserver la
paix mondiale gros succès à moscou
michel pascal la guerre des rambo fait
rage au cinéma après en bois et de et
avant rambo iii que vous verrez en
octobre moscou nous envoie le soviet
l'exacte réplique des exploits de
sylvester stallone version pays de l'est
la troisième guerre mondiale menace le
globe quelques militaires américains
corrompu tentent de déclencher un
affrontement entre les deux super grand
et des parrains officiers félons qui a
commis des massacres au vietnam bien
roger st remy s'ils sont déjà dirigées
contre la flotte russe quand arrive le
major château quine le nouveau rambour
venu du froid pour sauver le monde si la
mise en scène de soviets n'a pas
d'enfant faux l'efficacité du modèle
original
le film qui se veut une riposte à
l'impérialisme mais de nollywood ne
manque pas d'un certain éléments comme
vous allez en juger en écoutant cette
réplique qui fera date dans la guerre
froide au cinémovida
jeune homme en ce moment sur
j'aimerais être n'a pas
entendre le chant du rossignol
est-ce que c'est qu'en amérique il n'y a
pas de signal avant le climat est
néfaste pour eux
face tu parles
ce traître qu'il n'aime pas le pays et
fait elle possible
le soviet a fait un malheur en sûrs sous
des millions de spectateurs sont allés
applaudir les exploits de château keane
ridiculisant l'oncle sam
mais la différence entre rambo et son
émule russe c'est qu'il n'y aura jamais
de suite
ramboll se fait lâchement abattre dans
le dos au pays des soviets
même en période de glace nost on préfère
le patriotisme à la loi du profit
e
oui
demain il y à un tiercé en france cette
fois tiercé quarté donc c'est à enghien
voici les pronostics de pierrette brès
11 9 15 16 12 5 6 et 13 pour la fin de
ce journal le prochain rendez vous avec
l'information ce sera vers 23h10 avec
aubry et de l'air mais tout de suite une
météo complète avec laurent cabrol
sourire aux lèvres
excellente soirée sur antenne 2